hi everyone its charlie I got a lot of
requests to do more deleted scenes from
the Shazam movie they just released it
on digital so that's where all this new
footage is coming from this was meant to
be the alternate opening to the movie
that gives you a way bigger picture
about the brief explainer that he gives
on Black Adam and what happened with the
seven deadly sins thousands of years ago
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs in
there this is all stuff from the comics
that they're doing and we'll see a lot
of this during the Black Adam movie so
we'll break it down there's a new round
of that imax ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Suzanne or Black Adam
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this so this is
taking place a long time before the
actual beginning of the movie which was
supposed to be around 1974 I think where
he meets dr. sivana as a child because
as he sits down here at the end of this
scene he starts his seeking spell find
me someone pure of heart and then that's
later when dr. sivana as a child was
supposed to show up and they start with
the actual plot of the film but at the
very beginning of the deleted scene when
he burst through the door and then seals
it behind him so that no one can open it
he's coming from one of the other realms
of magic remember we're talking about
the magic lands the seven different
realms of magic that we're gonna see in
the Shazam sequel the backstory that he
gives about their fight with Black Adam
and what happened with the seven deadly
sins is actually way darker than I ever
thought that they would go in a movie
like this so it kind of makes sense why
they deleted it they didn't want to
spend too much of the film and
exposition explaining what happened with
Black Adam because they're leaving a lot
of that back story to be told during the
Black Adam movie and in general the tone
of the film was supposed to be a little
bit lighter more comedic in when he's
talking about what happened he says that
when Black Adam released the seven
deadly sins on conduct they then after
they got done polluting mankind so to
speak and unleashing all this chaos they
then turned on the magical council and
polluted them and caused this great
civil war he basically says that the
magical council turned on themselves
because they've been poisoned by the
seven deadly sins which is way more
hardcore than just saying the seven
deadly sins killed them like you saw
them trying to kill the kids during the
movie instead of trying to poison them
psychologically in getting the Shazam
family to turn on themselves maybe we'll
see something like that
The Blackout a movie I don't know
exactly how dark that's gonna be I still
think that it's gonna be pg-13 so not
that dark but after the magical council
killed themselves all but the wizard the
wizard was able to trap Black Adam using
his magic so he's still trapped
somewhere using the special enchantment
that's right out of the comics I'll
explain that in a second but then the
seven deadly sins just sort of scattered
to the other realms of magic so the
wizard had to go on this big quest to go
track them down and trap them one by one
in that special magical device so the
very beginning of this scene where he
bursts through the door is happening
right after he's finished that quest
like I've finally done it
thousands of years later finally trapped
the rest of you even if you haven't read
all the Shazam comics you probably
detected they're doing the new 52
Shazam Black Adam origin story mixed
with the newer DC rebirth seven realms
of the magic storyline especially
because of that post-credit scene but
the minor change that they made to the
backstories from the comic book story
were that in the comic version it was
just black Adam himself that killed all
the other members of the magical Council
except for the wizard Shazam he was able
to trap him for all time using a special
enchantment until dr. sivana who had the
ability to literally see magic with his
special eye they kind of did that during
the movie but they used a slightly
different twist with the seven deadly
sins to give him the special eye dr.
sivana seeking magic like he is during
this film finds the tomb and because he
can read magic he can see magical
enchantments he knows to say the word
Shazam and that releases black Adam from
his prison the rest of the comic book
story right up to the carnival fight at
the end is mostly dr. sivana riding
shotgun with Black Adam wall black Adam
himself releases the seven deadly sins
to create a bunch of chaos and keep
people busy long enough to try and trick
Billy into giving him all of his powers
just like Savannah does during the movie
version the rock himself explained that
when they were first conceiving of this
origin story in black Adam was in the
Shazam movie they decided that there was
way too much explaining to do because
they're trying to make black Adam this
really huge character I mean the rock
was gonna be the biggest star in it so
naturally you want a lot of the movie to
focus on developing his character but
they couldn't do that and develop the
Shazam family this
time without the film just completely
getting overblown so it was the rock
himself that went to Warner Brothers and
asked for permission to separate the
origin stories into a Black Adam movie
and then ashes a movie so that is why
the rock did not actually star himself
in the Shazam movie but all the
characters at the end of that comic book
story wind up in the same place as they
do at the end of the Shazam movie at the
end of the comic book mr. mine comes to
dr. sivana and tells him about the seven
realms of magic just like he did in the
post-credits scene the part that they're
saving for the Black Adam movie is
someone coming along and either
willingly or unwittingly releasing Black
Adam from his magical prison into
present day and eventually he'll set his
sights on taking the Shazam family's
powers for his own I haven't heard
anything about mark Strong's dr. sivana
being in the Black Adam film so I don't
expect him to show up during that so
obviously they'll have to change a
couple more things because they used so
much of the comic book origin story for
the first Shazam film there were rumors
that part of the Black Adam movies story
was going to be based on Black Adam the
Dark Age comic book during that he tries
to resurrect his wife with the help of
Felix Faust who winds up double-crossing
him I'm not expecting a literal
adaptation of that entire story he has
the entire Justice Society after him
trying to trap him but it's happening at
the end of a long series of battles that
he's had with the Justice Society so
it's not exactly a story that you would
start off with but it does paint him as
an antihero instead of being just a
straight-up villain and obviously
because it's the rock Dwayne Johnson
he's gonna be playing more of an
antihero so just expect him to spin
Black Adam that way really good example
of the rock doing that with the
character is him showing up for the
first time in the Fast and Furious
franchise he showed up as an antagonist
a cop that was chasing down Vin Diesel
in the crew he was just supposed to be
this angry badass character that was
absolutely certain he was on the side of
law and order black Adams alignment in
the comics was more like lawful evil
he's a dr. doom style character he rules
over conduct with an iron fist
he has very clear ideas about what's
right what's wrong how to punish people
with the bureaucracy should be just like
Doctor Doom ruling over Latveria he does
seem like a really terrible person but
it's not all chaos and burning
everything to the ground he definitely
wants to preserve life in his home state
but he just doesn't care about anybody
else outside of that a lot of what they
do during the blackout a movie will just
depend on how much money they spend on
it I assumed that because they only
spent about a hundred million dollars
making the Shazam movie they'll probably
spend a little bit more because it's the
rock he's a much bigger box office draw
internationally so it's a little easier
to justify a higher budget for that
movie so maybe closer to like a hundred
and fifty million dollars but we'll
probably find out about that later this
year don't worry they're supposed to
start shooting the Black Adam movie next
year let me know in the comments though
what do you actually want Black Adam to
be doing in present day before he sort
of sets his target sights on the Shazam
family really awesome stuff coming up
Comic Con is next week so brace yourself
for all the trailers when we get to next
week I'll do a scheduled video sometime
early in the week just explain which
videos I've already planning on doing
but there's always a bunch of surprises
so if you have any special requests for
videos during Comic Con next week just
let me know in the comments below and
I'll try to add it to my list and as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see all the Comic Con
videos when I post them so no worries
but congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last big video Arnolds
kay please email me on the about page of
my channel so I can get your details
click here for that other Shazam black
adam deleted scene and click here for
all my spider-man far from home Easter
eggs and post credits scenes thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]